nous avons rencontré le père de l'une
des victimes du 13 novembre ce jour là
le fils d mal à s'habiller dit l'insee
fait tuer devant le bistrot à la bonne
hier je vous propose d'écouter elle son
témoignage
au moment où j'allais appeler je reçois
un appel de son frère et me dit papa et
je vais venir j'ai quelque chose à te
dire en urgence en arrivant il avait une
tête toute pâle
j'ai dit mon fils qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est pas mal dormi dit non non non je
viens d'apprendre ou très mauvaise
nouvelle c'est didier qui fait partie de
la liste des victimes des attentats de
taille dans le monde s'est écroulé
autour de moi savais plus où j'étais il
m'avait fait pas de son voeu d'aller
continuer à la sorbonne j'étais très
heureux pour lui j'étais l'un très fier
parce que je lui avais dit que paris
c'est une p de la lumière se paie de la
connaissance tu vas tu es pas nuire et
pis certains pays où la paix règne
depuis longtemps donc au contraire de ce
que nous avions vécu nous durant les dix
années de
le terrorisme en algérie ce journal
selon les dires des gens il faisait très
beau le temps était agréable
lui c'est un grand marcheur il a
beaucoup marché il a dit à son ami will
elle je veux retourner avec toi j'ai
envie de marcher on attendait c'est beau
c'est bon puis un retour et revenez par
la rue fontaine au roi
et c'est là que la fusillade a lieu il a
été touché par une balle fatale voilà ça
a été très dur et ça l'est toujours là
après moi je me suis dit si je flanche
j'ai d'autres enfants
ça veut dire que toute ma famille
va être dans le désarroi total
donc j'ai pris mon courage à deux mains
et j'ai dit déjà que la maman n'est pas
là il fallait maintenant jouer le rôle
des deux dans le rôle d'une maman je ne
sais pas tellement faire les essais pour
perpétuer la
la mémoire de ligne n
j'ai créé une fondation on a prévu pour
le 13 novembre de cette année 2
d'organiser un concert conjointement
avec la formule
il fallait que j'assiste à ce procès
pour
un devoir de mémoire envers lui voilà
c'est cette raison qui m'a amené à venir
et a participé et même à à demeurer
jusqu'à la fin du procès jeudi que
l'acte de d'assassinât de mon fils et
des autres
des autres victimes
ne ne doit pas être justifiée par le
fait que
la religion le permet que pour n'importe
quel motif on peut liquider x ou y je
dis que l'islam est une religion de paix
de
d'amour de partage de générosité et de
tolérance
pour moi c'est des gens que je ne
considère pas comme des humains risque
et ils ont commis des actes abominables
et ça ne peut pas être un humain qui
fait ça mais ça n'empêchera que ça
restera un procès historique
qui
kim aura quand même dont les l'occasion
de soulager ma conscience voilà